let's have a look here Brian's provided
us with a factorization for this top
question X plus 8 X minus 5 do you agree
what's good to me fantastic
so he's factorized first and then he
looks at each of his factors and scenes
excuse me
each factor gives him a solution but X
plus 8 factor gives him this solution
and the X minus 5 factor gives him this
one thumbs-up
great job it's pretty much it's flawless
now we have a look at the second one
wherever I said to you I gave you the
clue that you should complete the square
here but for you what should twig in
your mind is you look at a question like
this is I can't think of a pair of
numbers that adds to this and
multipliers so this I just can't come up
with what it should take you about 10 to
15 seconds to look at that and say I
can't think of an answer and that's fine
that's why we had this nice or upgraded
tool right so you can see we've done a
few things here what areum is done is
actually not exactly the way that I
suggest you do it yesterday but it still
works perfectly what he wants is a
perfect square that's built out of this
right so he looks at that plus six and
he says we've got to do two things do
you remember what the two things were
you have an N square you have and then
square when you have you get three when
you square you get nine now we don't
have nine well you have a four so what a
ribbon zone is added what to both sides
have a look he's added five to both
sides right that that turns his foreign
into a nine which is exactly what we
need
if you had an intervening line before
that that's okay you should have still
ended up with the five on the right hand
side and once you've got this that's a
square ruler I said to you before it
doesn't look like a square but it's an
algebraic version of a square so he's
factorized it as a square he's taking
the square root and then from the second
last line to the last line what has he
done
have a look carefully what operation has
you don't
he has subtracted three from the left
and from the right now
Andrew asked a great question earlier
which was I do we just leave it like
that or do we remember the fact that
actually this is shorthand for two
numbers right and you might want to just
for the sake of illustration you might
want to write with me this is short for
minus 3 minus root 5 that's one of the
answers and then the other answer is
minus 3 plus 3 5 that's why there's plus
or minus there so this is actually what
we mean now do we have to write this
last line do we have to write it out as
two answers the short answer is no the
short answer is no you can leave it here
and that's that's awesome it's nice and
succinct you've got all the information
that you need however sometimes we do
want to write it as 2 and I will show
you an example just put your pens down
for minute and look up
suppose we went through this process
okay and on this last line here instead
of getting minus 3 plus or minus the
square root of 5 suppose my last line
said this okay suppose like the numbers
ended up with a 49 underneath the square
root now we know what 49 is it's a
special number it's 7 squared so I
actually can take take the square root
of 49 it gives me this okay now this is
still true this is still two solutions
but because it's not assert anymore
because it's just whole numbers right
you're like I know what minus 3 minus 7
is what's minus 3 minus 7 minus 10 and I
know what minus 3 plus 7 is as well it's
4 now clearly this is better like it's
just look there's the two numbers just
like you're used to
ok so writing it just like this is fine
but in the case where it's like oh
they're not square roots anymore I
actually can come back like terms then
then you should okay does that make
sense